i don't take anything seriously and i i
i find it
hilarious when people try to take what i
do very seriously
aaron reynolds is the creator of viral
meme accounts like
swear trek and effin birds which
features serene woodcut style renderings
of
birds paired with profane maxims like
get some [ __ ] popcorn it's [ __ ]
showtime
and someone should shove bees up your
ass i don't have to
you know yell at people or punch the
wall
i can make a bird very angry and put it
on the internet
and then feel great about it in the
lead-up to the 2020 election just as
reynolds effin bird's instagram was
exploding
so was panic over so-called
disinformation
under pressure from lawmakers tech
platforms crack down
on content deemed unacceptable by their
algorithms and human moderators
reynolds is based in canada but 80
percent of his audience is american
and instagram determined that the effing
birds account had run afoul of the
platform's rules aimed at stopping
foreign election interference i needed
to turn on location services
because they were concerned about
accounts that had a large reach and they
wanted to make sure that people knew
where those
accounts were located i was like okay
they're you know they're looking for
election misinformation and stuff like
that and
it's all images they can't tell a a meme
uh with election disinformation from a
picture of a bird and the word butt
sauce
instagram initially added a location
label to all of reynolds posts
indicating his account was based in
canada and he proceeded as normal
but then the company permanently removed
effenbird's
from its american explore page which is
a recommended list of posts instagram
shows to users based on their
preferences
and the post's popularity site-wide
effin bird's reach on the platform
plummeted
on every post i would see that i would
get somewhere between five and ten
thousand
views from the explore page and today
i get zero on every post no matter how
popular
so did instagram abuse its market power
by limiting reynolds ability to reach
new audiences
i'm not owed their spotlight on their
platform that's their platform
but i think the hard part of it is
having had that pulled
because i'm a dirty foreigner kind of
sucks
you know reynolds distributes his
content across
multiple popular platforms to mitigate
his risk
the reason that i'm on instagram in the
first place is because i was stressed
out about something like that happening
on twitter
the algorithms are going to change and
so if you put all your eggs in the
basket of that algorithm
uh you're you're screwed reynolds says
that quirky outlets like his could never
have found an audience before social
media
which is what led to the publication of
his new book available now in hardcover
effin birds a field guide to
identification
nobody wanted to put me on the radio or
television and nobody wanted to publish
a book
until it was popular on twitter i'm not
retreating to legacy media i'm just
finding another
platform in that platform as bookstores
bookstores have been
great you know there's there's this sort
of magic of learning
that if you get in good with like an
indie book chain they'll sell a ton of
your books
because they love you like the number
three seller
behind amazon and barnes noble was
a like boston area chain called newbury
comics
and i was like who are these guys and
can i send them all cakes
reynolds says his experience with
instagram isn't an existential threat to
his meme business but he does worry
about the potential danger of allowing
the government
through explicit regulation or through
its influence over tech companies
to constrain online speech if there's
government involvement we'll have the
same kind of problems they'll just be
different or government-mandated
versions of those problems i think it's
funny that i'm lumped in with threats
to democracy and i post pictures of
birds and swear words